you don't have enough troopers out there
being able to work those freeways and
anybody work driving those freeways
every day
have them just look and see if they see
a trooper
so when was the last time you saw a
state police trooper on the side of the
road well tonight the union representing
those men and women is sounding the
alarm saying at some points there are
just a handful of police monitoring our
major freeways and roads as the 8 news
now i-team's david sharn shows us they
fear this is shaping up to be a recipe
for disaster
do you need police fire or medical
please
michael dufrese started a recent early
morning commute by calling 9-1-1 and a
guy turned down the durango sunset
actually going the wrong way
he's like a lot of las vegas drivers
i see guys
going by at 90 miles an hour
on this day dufrese was pulling onto the
215 near durango when that driver
started going the wrong way if anybody's
on that off ramp
they're going to hit somebody or kill
somebody already he says by the time he
got to a state police dispatcher the car
was out of sight he doesn't know if a
trooper ever responded i see very little
during during the day
much less there's even less at night
we have shifts day shifts that have six
troopers working the valley graveyards
maybe three or four sometimes three or
four troopers covering the entire las
vegas valley overnight wayne dice is
with the nevada police union in my
almost 29 years law enforcement i've
never seen this before he says nevada
state police highway patrol is seeing a
50 percent vacancy rate records obtained
by the 8 news now i-team show a total of
92 uniformed officers for the entire las
vegas valley in 2014. that number fell
to 72 last year the union says it's now
60. you don't have enough troopers out
there being able to work those freeways
and anybody driving those freeways every
day
have them just look and see if they see
a trooper a presentation given to the
legislature last year included these
startling statements most highways are
not covered on graveyard highway patrol
may get to the point where they must
turn away certain calls for service and
response time to calls for service will
continue to increase look at our
fatality crashes
speed and impaired driving are the
reasons why we have these fatalities and
this is a record year the 8 news now
i-team asked the department of public
safety for average response times in
2020 for southern command it took an
average 19 minutes and 41 seconds for
someone to respond up from 1816 and 2019
and 1724 in 2018 this is for all of
southern nevada including our rural
counties it's a huge difference
in manpower right now
382 people died on nevada roads last
year up nearly 20 percent from the year
before the top causes impairment and
speeding amid the rise the union says
members of the department's dui task
force are being pulled to cover other
ships this is an issue that has to be
addressed right now because every week
that goes by we have more people leaving
it makes absolutely no sense for drivers
like dufrese seeing fewer troopers on
the roads as our valley expands is
alarming the chances of this happening
and somebody getting caught
you know when you're doing 100 miles an
hour down the street or down a freeway
you're covering a lot of time the job
posting right now for entry level
officers at dps shows 65 vacancies the
union worries with a small pot of
candidates the state isn't being
competitive in salary we'll dig into
that tuesday here at 6. i'm david charns
live local now